la argentina continúa con paso firme el
país empezó a inocular la segunda dosis
de la vacuna rusa sputnik son 300.000
para personal de salud además argentina
en su colaboración con méxico envió al
país azteca el principio activo de la
vacuna de astrazéneca para que sea
envasado y empaquetado está llenado
involucra a un laboratorio externa
argentina como ustedes recordarán que
produce el principio activo lomas de
méxico y aquí en méxico laboratorio
mortal es el llenado y envasado fidel y
de ahí se distribuye la méxico y de toda
américa latina brasil también muestra su
potencial tras iniciar la inoculación de
la vacuna china sinovac el ejército se
mueve por tierra mar y aire hasta llegar
al amazonas donde los antropólogos
habían avisado que el kobe 19 ponía en
peligro formas de vida ancestrales
la vacunación es muy importante para
toda nuestra comunidad indígena para
todos los aldeanos era esto lo que
estábamos esperando pero el ritmo no
avanza igual en toda américa latina
colombia en pleno pico de la pandemia
por el momento sólo puede mostrar
almacenes para albergar 50 millones de
vacunas hasta menos 80 grados
centígrados el país cuenta con más de 3
mil contenedores portátiles que
permitirán llegar a las zonas más
remotas ya podemos decir a los
colombianos ya quienes habitan el
territorio colombiano
y no nacionales que por supuesto estamos
preparados para el recibo de las vacunas
y su aplicación la región continúa
luchando por conseguir unas vacunas que
están en manos de los países más ricos
mientras los sistemas de salud continúan
al límite ante los rebrotes causados por
la pandemia de kobe 19